CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
In this video, what I'd like us
to do is answer some questions
I've posed here in a
really long problem.
So let me take us through it.
So we're going to consider
a position vector that's
described by x of t, y of t, 0.
I want to have it
in three-space so I
can take a cross product later.
And then we're going to
suppose that it actually
has constant length.
And that when I look at the
acceleration vector at t,
it's actually equal to
a constant times r of t,
where the constant is not 0.
OK?
So I can, these
are the two things
I know about this
position vector.
It has constant length.
For all t, it has
constant length.
And the acceleration is always
equal to some constant times
the position.
OK, that's what I'm giving you.
And now I want you to use
those things and vector
differentiation to show
that r dot v is equal to 0,
where v is the velocity.
And then to show that
r cross v is constant.
So you're going to have to
figure out-- essentially,
the thing you have
to figure out is
what relationship do you
want to differentiate
to show these two things.
OK?
That's the hard part
of this problem.
And then, I went
to see if you can
give an example of such an r.
So if you can give an
example of a position vector
that has these properties.
And maybe if you're
having a hard time,
the first thing for you to do
might be to think about this,
and to see if you can figure
out an example of that,
and then see kind of how things
work together in that example.
That may actually
proved helpful.
So why don't you work on this
problem, pause the video,
and then when you're feeling
good about your answer,
you can bring the video back up
and I'll show you how I do it.
OK, welcome back.
So there was a lot to
do in this problem,
but let me just remind
you what the framework is.
We have a position vector, and
we know two things about it.
We know that it
has constant length
and we know that the
acceleration is always
equal to some constant
times the position.
I didn't give you
the constant, but we
know it's always equal to some
constant times the position.
And then we wanted to
show two things using
vector differentiation.
We wanted to show
that r dot v was 0.
And we wanted to show that
r cross v was constant.
And then we want to talk
about what is an example.
So let's start off and
see if we can figure out
how to show that r
dot v is equal to 0.
And, you know, as you're
thinking about this problem,
something that you
want to remember
as you're thinking
about this is, well,
what are the things that I know?
I know that r dot r
is constant, so I'm
going to write that down.
r dot r-- I'm not
going to say is
equal to c, because that's a
different constant-- so I'll
just, let me just call it c_1.
OK?
That's a different
constant than my c, maybe.
OK, I know that r dot
r is some constant,
and I want to show something
about r dot v. Right?
So if I'm looking
at this and I say,
well, I know this thing here.
So it's the only dot product
relationship that I have.
Because right now, I know a
relationship between a and r,
and I know r has
constant length.
Since that's all
I gave you, if I
want to look at a
dot product, this
is the relationship I know.
The constant length thing.
And so I know I somehow have
to use this one to figure out
something about r dot v.
OK.
Well, what's the point
that we should realize?
What is v?
v is d/dt of r.
So I could take the
derivative-- if I
could take the derivative
of just one of these things,
then I would get
r dot v down here.
Right?
If I took d/dt of
just one of these,
I would get the r dot v.
And d/dt of this is 0.
But I can't do that, right?
Because if I take d/dt
of this whole thing,
I'm going to end up having
to differentiate this r once
and leave this
alone, and I'm going
to have to differentiate
this r and leave this alone.
But if you heard what
I was just saying,
maybe you see that that's
actually still going to be OK.
So let's look at what happens.
I mean, this is all really
I have to work with,
so I'm going to explore.
Let's look at what happens
when I take d/dt of r dot r.
And I'm going to start
leaving off the hats here,
because I'm going to
leave them off somewhere,
so we'll just
leave them off now,
and then I won't leave
some off and put some on.
So from here on out, I'm just
going to write r, v, and a
without that hats,
but they're vectors.
OK.
So d/dt of r dot r, well,
I have to take d/dt of r,
and then I dot that
with r, and then
I take r dotted with--
sorry-- d/dt of r.
Right?
Well, what do I get here?
d/dt of r we said was v,
so that's v dot r.
And what do I get here?
This is r dot-- there's d/dt
of r again-- so I get r dot v.
Now the great thing
about the dot product
is that if I switch
the order of these two,
it's still the same thing.
So I can just write
this as-- well, I'll
switch the order of this one.
So they both look like
r dot v plus r dot v,
and that means I get
2 r dot v. Right?
So d/dt of r dot r
is actually 2 of r
dotted with v-- the position
dotted with the velocity.
Now why is this
going to help me?
Because what do I know
about this quantity r dot r?
I know it's constant, right?
So what is d/dt of a constant?
d/dt of a constant is 0.
So I actually started off
with knowing this was 0.
So if I go through
the whole chain,
I see 0 is equal to-- let me
put the 0 down here again-- 0 is
equal to 2 r dot v, and so r
dot v I know is equal to 0.
What does that
mean geometrically?
That means r and
v are orthogonal.
And where is v going to sit?
Well, if I come back over
to how I described r,
r is in the xy-plane, right?
The z-component is 0.
So if I differentiate--
if I take
d/dt of r-- I'm going to
have the derivative of x
as a function of t.
And then whatever y
is as a function of t,
I take that derivative.
And this is still 0.
So v is going to
sit in the xy-plane,
and based on what
we know so far,
we know it's actually
orthogonal to r.
So they make a 90-degree
angle at all times t.
OK, and how did
we do that again?
I just want to
remind you, we knew
one dot product
relationship, that
was r dot r was a constant.
So we differentiated that and
tried to see what happened.
And the main point
at the end of it,
was that when I had a v dot r, I
could rewrite it as an r dot v,
and so I just end up
with two of something
that I want to know about.
So that's the main
idea of the first part.
Now the second part was
I asked you to figure out
something over here.
We wanted to know that
r cross v is constant.
OK?
And t, it's always the same.
All right?
So let's think about
if I want to show
that for every t
something is constant,
I could show-- actually, I've
sort of seen it already--
I could show that
its derivative is 0.
OK.
So if r cross v is constant--
or if its derivative is 0,
I should say-- then r
cross v was constant.
Right?
If its derivative is 0 for all
t, then r cross v is constant.
Right?
So that's really what
we want to exploit here.
So let's look at the idea.
So we want to-- again,
let me write it down--
show r cross v is constant.
And the strategy
we're going to use
is to do this we're going to
show that d/dt of r cross v
is equal to 0.
Right?
If we can show that, then
this means that for all t
it's the same.
It's not changing in t.
Right?
So for all t, r cross v
is going to be the same,
so r cross v is
going to be constant.
So the difference
between the two problems
was in the first problem
you didn't quite know maybe
what expression you needed
to differentiate to find
what you were looking for.
Here, we know what we
need to differentiate,
but we have to make
sure we understand--
to show this is constant--
when we differentiate,
we should get 0.
OK?
So that's sort of a slightly
different type of problem.
And I'm asking you maybe
from the other side here.
So let's now--
let's just see what
we get on the left-hand side.
So what's d/dt of r cross v?
Well, d/dt of r is v, right?
So we get v cross v
for the first term.
So take d/dt of r, we get
v. We leave this v alone,
and then we add to that, r cross
d/dt of v-- what's d/dt of v?
That's a.
Right?
Now, let's take a look at this.
Well, v cross v, v is
pointing in the same direction
as itself.
So when you try and take
a cross product of that,
you know that the
length of your vector
should be the area of
the parallelogram formed
by these two vectors.
But v is pointing in the
same direction as itself,
so there's no area there.
That's a geometric
interpretation
of why this thing should be 0.
Another reason is that
remember that your v cross
v is going to
include a sine theta
term, where theta is the angle
between the two vectors, right?
That's another formula you have.
And so when you look at the
angle between this vector
and itself, it's 0.
And sine 0 is 0.
So this is, in fact,
0 in that part.
So if this is 0, then
we get what we want.
Well, I only gave
you one other bit
of information in the problem.
And if you remember,
it was that a is always
equal to a constant times r.
So I can rewrite
this right-hand side
as r cross a constant times r.
And because of properties
of these cross products,
I can pull out the constant.
Or I can actually,
I guess I don't
need to pull it out
to talk about it,
but it's nicer if I pull it out.
And look at what I have here.
I have the exact same
situation as v cross v. I mean,
this is still pointing
in the same direction.
Constant times r and r still
point in the same direction
as if I were to compare r and r.
So I didn't have to
pull out the constant,
but then right
here it's very easy
to see that this is also 0.
So I had 0 plus
this, so I get 0.
So, I've shown through
this process-- maybe
I should have written
equal signs here--
that d/dt of r cross v
is actually equal to 0.
And so you see that this cross
product between r and v--
which we know are orthogonal
sitting in the xy plane--
that it's always the same,
it's always the same vector.
And now I asked you
to give an example,
and maybe you
thought of an example
first, and then thought
of how it worked.
And so the easiest example is if
you let r of t equal cosine t,
sine t.
So the easiest example--
there are others, obviously--
is if you let r of t equal
cosine t, sine t comma 0.
Sorry, I was thinking about
it in three-space, right?
And in fact, if I were to scale
this, it would still work.
I could put any
constant in front.
This carves out-- if I
let t go between 0 and 2
pi, or even minus
infinity to infinity,
I'm just carving
out vectors that
are-- the position vector
is always on the unit
circle on this case.
Right?
If I put a constant in front,
it's on another circle.
So for whatever values of t
I'm letting myself vary over,
all the vectors are going to
lie on some part of a circle.
OK?
And so this is maybe
the easy example.
Maybe you want to
calculate, just
to give yourself some practice,
what v of t is and what a of t
actually is.
What these two quantities
actually are, and then look
at what happens.
What happens with r and v, and
see why r dot v is equal to 0.
What you should see-- I'll try
and give you a picture of it
geometrically.
What you should see
is that, you know,
if this is-- we'll see
if I can effectively
do a two-dimensional drawing
in three-space-- if this is
the r I'm looking at, that v
has to be coming in this way,
out this way.
So there's r and there's v.
And this angle-- because I'm
trying to squash what
was a circle-- I guess
I'll look from above first.
My picture, from
above, is looking
like something like this.
There's r and there's v,
and that's a right angle.
Right?
So if I look from-- coming
down on to the xy-plane,
here's a position vector,
here's its velocity,
they're orthogonal.
And as I move all the
way around the circle,
that position vector
and the velocity
are going to keep
that relationship.
When I look at this-- I'm trying
to insert in the z-axis here.
When I look at this,
if I look at what
is the cross product
of these two vectors,
well it's always going to
point in the z-direction.
It's going to point straight
in the z-direction from here.
Because it's orthogonal
to both of these,
it's going to point
straight in the z-direction.
I know r is constant length.
I can then see v
is constant length
from the example I have here.
And as I rotate,
I'm going to get
that this is constant length.
OK?
So this is where
the picture of what
we were actually describing
very much more generally
in the first part of this.
So the main point that I want
us to see in this problem
is that when we want to find
information about relationships
between r, v, and a--
this position and velocity
and acceleration--
what we can do
is differentiate
these vector fields.
We saw an example when
you were looking at I
think Kepler's second law
you saw this in lecture.
But I just want to show
you that you can use this
if you don't necessarily
know explicitly
things about a position vector.
You can still find out
things about its relationship
if you're given
some information.
You don't actually
have to have a formula
to find out some information
about these relationships.
So I think that's
where I'll stop.